The aria design practices' advice for
the radio group Pattern notes.
It is recommended that both the radio
group and the radio button have a label
that is visible and referenced
using the aria-labelledby property.
And use an aria-describedby property to
add additional information to the radio
buttons or radio group.
Aria provides several mechanisms for
adding labels and
descriptions to elements.
In fact, aria is the only way to add
accessible help or description text.
Let's take a look at the properties
aria provides to enable us to create
accessible labels.
Aria-label allows us to specify
a string directly to be
used as the accessible label.
One situation in which you might use an
aria-label attribute is where you have
some kind of visual indication
as to the purpose of an element.
But still need to clarify that for
anyone who might not be able to
access that visual indication,
such as a button which uses
a graphic to indicate its purpose.
This overrides any other native labeling
mechanism such as a label element.
Or for example, if a button has both
text content and an aria-label,
only the aria-label value will be used.
Aria-labelledby allows us
to specify an element ID
to refer to another element in
the dumb as this element's label.
Aria-labelledby is much like we're
using a label element with some key
differences.
Aria-labelledby may be
used on any element.
Aria-labelledby is much like using a
label element with some key differences.
Aria-labelledby may be used on any
element, not just labellable elements.
While a label element refers
to the thing it labels,
the relationship is reversed
in the case of aria-laelledby.
The thing which is labeled refers
to the thing which labels it.
Since aria only affects
the accessibility tree,
aria-laelledby by does not
give you the nice label
clicking behavior you get
from the label element.
Aria-labelledby can take a list
of ID refs to compose a label
out of multiple elements.
The label will be concatenated in
the order the ID refs are given.
And aria-labelledby can refer
to elements which are otherwise
hidden from assistive technology.
Aria-labelledby overrides all
other name sources for an element.
So for example, if something has both
an aria-labelledby and an aria label.
Or an aria-labelledby and
a native HTML label,
the aria-labelledby label
will always take precedence.